ich habe als ich vor meinen augen von
hinten angegriffen hat und da habe ich
meine angst verloren und dann habe ich
nur da gedacht dass ich ihn stoppen muss
eigentlich versuchen muss dass er nicht
weitere menschen töten kann
ich habe leider keine hat ich habe
niemanden
ich hab' ich habe ich war dann alleine
ich bin auch gerutscht und bin zu boden
gefallen das hat die regen hätte ich
nicht so wurden und aber ich habe zwar
im vorjahr ich habe dann versucht wieder
auf die beine zu kommen damit auf den
film kann man diese szene nicht sehen
leider
diese fiel mit diesen aufnahmen die man
sieht die die schläge die ich schon
verpasst habe und auch die versuche die
ich unternommen habe
ich wollte ihm das messer abnehmen aber
das ist mir nicht gelungen
er hat keinen laut von sich gegeben er
hat ja auch eine maske getragen
dass er das irgendwie vielleicht etwas
getrunken hat der alkohol so das kann
ich auch nicht sagen ich kann nicht
sagen in welchem zustand sich gefahren
ich habe nur gesehen dass er schuldlose
menschen unschuldige menschen getötet
hat und jeden den er traf hatte hat er
mit messer verletzt und diese stehen
konnte ich nicht ertragen
ich wollte etwas tun damit ich ihn
stoppen konnte ich halte eine nutzer
grad ich habe in damit schaffen können
und als helden bezeichnet
ich habe ich habe das aus aus dem
inneren aus innere überzogen wird von
militärs gründen gemacht und
viele sind geflohen viele haben angst
gehabt aber ich bin nach vorlegen und
ich habe mein leben in gefahr gebracht
weil wegen der menschen die in diesem
lande mir zuflucht gewährt haben
und ich habe nur das getan ich bitte sie
mich nicht als helden wird zu bezeichnen
ich habe nicht gesagt ich hatte das war
nur eine humanitäre handlung das war
meine um meine meine pflicht ich bin
auch sehr froh dass ich ihn ein bisschen
daran hindern konnte und wir noch
traurig darüber dass ich nicht früher da
war um ihn gänzlich zu stoppen und
vielleicht hätte ich dazu beitragen
können das vielleicht nur eine person
getötet wurde und deswegen bin ich auch
sehr traurig dass so viele menschen
getötet wurden